uh but i will i will say
uh huge congratulations to uh
to um to abi mishra from
united states who became the youngest
grandmaster of all time
it's pretty uh
pretty nice achievement and i would say
especially
considering that he went to
he went to hungary to to play basically
non-stop i i feel like for
for a couple of months now uh and to
to get his norms and um i could see on
on one hand
that um gives you a better
better chance to to get the norms but it
also
it also means that i mean these
tournaments are practically organized
for you to achieve this particular aim
so it also
puts a lot of a lot of pressure on you
so i'm
really impressed that he that he
achieved this fit
and minus we did talk to him uh earlier
today and he said
he likes so much to work with chassis he
plays and practices 12 hours
every day do you relate to that at all
when you were 12.
yeah certainly when i was 12 there was
very little
like deliberate practice as you call it
but
i certainly work with um doing something
chess related
uh non-stop and uh it sounds like
sounds like he's somebody who can uh who
has a lot of love
for for jazz and has the potential to
to be a very strong very strong player
have you seen some of his games magnus
do you predict anything for his future
uh from what i can see
he's a typical young player in the in
the sense that he
he calculates well he fights well and he
can
he can sometimes um
make he can sometimes evaluate positions
but um
i also think like we shouldn't proclaim
anybody who's
12 years old the future future world
champion
i don't think that's that's healthy but
um you know it's it's a good start
well he did say that you are his biggest
inspiration magnus so i bet he's very
happy to
see your match victory today so
congratulations and good luck tomorrow
thank you thanks for joining us and we